okay
back to the basics so um
he's gonna do that the push stroke okay
so he's going and i'm going to um
work my internal aspects now don't
confuse
my internal aspects with biomechanical
advantage
okay biomechanical advantage is external
it's material internal aspects
is not material it's energetic so
he's he's he's uh pinning me down and
the fact that i can lift him up
is not exter is not internal
got it it's external internal is not
what i do with my body
or even his body but what i do with his
energy with the energy such that
you can be mechanically unsound
and internally sound okay
so we're not dealing with biomechanical
efficiency
so as he goes i have my yielding
techniques so i'm going to yield
but that would be external
the internal aspect is the friction
that i create through an ikea adhesion
so
in other words i'm not going like this
i'm
stuck i'm stuck to him okay
so he tries to go backwards and hit the
backwards
he's going to feel the the uh
friction okay so he goes it's not just
moving out of the way
not just moving out of the way but stuck
push stop pull stuck
that's the internal aspect okay
so i have an external yin move and an
internal yin moo which is the ikea
adhesion
okay then he's gonna go again
and because it's a yin yang world i also
have
an external there's an external
kind of separating mechanics in other
words uh
my arms are between he and i but the
internal
is energetic and it's a call q so he
pushes
and i aim that up and i'm sorry down and
through his center
so yin pull
with the eye key push with this
and he's gonna push and i'll aim that
into his center
and we're gonna go so he's trying to hit
me here i'm trying to not let him
and uh work these mechanics this mixture
of yin
and yang of ikey and pokey
and when i'm doing this i because my art
works like this i use those
internal aspects ikea and coq
to generate kazushi which means i
deconstruct
his base of support by
taking his line of gravity outside of
his base of support
okay this this is kazushi so wool
and you see i'm doing that
but not by moving him external
his energy is coming in hitting the
ground and i'm
shooting it back into his center
okay another way of looking at this is
through the classical cosmology
so i have heaven man
earth but heaven
is energy it's immaterial
and that energy that immateriality
whether it is god or the divine
or tin or tea or the kami
it comes in to me it comes in to me
hits the ground hits earth comes back
out it goes back into where it came from
it's
immaterial self okay so the heaven man
earth model is the same thing he's
coming into me i let it go through me so
uh push it's just going to the ground
going it's going through me going
through me to the ground
it's not pushing me up here it goes
through me
just like um you know
jing kong kishim so the deities coming
into me the immaterial is coming into me
hitting the earth and it goes back
out of me boom
i want to feel it come into me
okay let's go so you're you're out here
you don't feel anything right let go
do you see your knees okay do you see
that so
where wherever i touch oh in your body
okay and i'm not out here by the hands
not out here by the hands
okay right when we touch boom in your
body
you see now just because i'm in your
body doesn't mean i'm doing
aikido's tactical architectures okay
so i might be doing go ahead i'm in your
body you see
but this architecture is not aikido
so i'm going to get the tilts
you see the tilts
so i um see that front inward and
outward because
she says see what watch your head i'm
going to tilt you
you see come on
you feel the pull yeah okay so i can
start testing my
uh my eye key so watch you'll feel it
see you feel that so it's
it's not ike's not grabbing you
it's adhering i missed you there but got
you here
right here you see you feel
this right there
okay so both in
cook you in cook you if i'm slippery
you see i have to do external
pushing okay but
in the same eye key you feel you feel it
okay in the same eye key i have to use
it in my coq so
rather than pushing like this i can go
up your arm you see that
without slipping so
watch when you project
it turns external you see
keep the adhesion and i
i like to do that
because it helps develop the skill
so once you project
see how i pull on it so
pull right here keeping it going
okay get in the center
go um
so
i aikido people this is their art but
they
they don't understand it okay because
it's not really an understandable thing
okay i mean i could explain the
cosmology which is just analogy and
metaphor
it you're not going to be able to go
have man earth heaven man earth man
heaven earth you could say it a million
times it won't be
you won't be able to do it and the
language is so
unimportant you could change it
right you could go bologna lettuce bread
bologna lettuce bread and you'll figure
it out or you won't figure it out
okay so as as he's going
he's he's trying to hit that you see
every time i if i go like that he needs
to cut oh
he went for the second one you see so
i'm gonna go
external he's gonna
he's trying to get that do some of your
traps too there he goes you see
i've got push on it he's going to go
around it boom
this kind of thing so he's he's trying
to do
these things okay
but you look at it and you want to say
why
isn't he doing those things he is trying
to do those things
okay so if he goes like this let's say
he's going to go around he's going to do
a trap this way
okay so that's what he's trying to do
and you'll see he breaks contact
he's breaking contact not because of
what he's doing
because it's a codependent world you see
that's the world view the fourth
discipline
he broke he breaks contact because i
pushed over here
see if he doesn't say one
then you want to go why why didn't he
try he did try
but i did not break contact with him and
then he did not break contact with me
do you see that so he he's gonna go
around
and i'm back where we started you see
and he's gonna try to go around and i'm
following his hand
that's all i'm doing this is your your
iki ken
i follow his sword around follow his
sword around
you see that's how we don't break
contact
okay if i try to push on
something he is trained he knows how to
go around
or use the other hand or what have you
okay
but when i move with him he it doesn't
work
because i'm staying with him
now i want to stay with him in a way
that i get the kazushi pattern
do you see that there's the front inward
kazushi pattern
i don't want to just stay with him
he's trying to hit that thing and i'm
this i don't want to do that
i i have an agenda to do i stay with him
but i take him into the front inward
kazushi pattern
okay or the outward kazushi pattern
i don't just stay with him okay
so i stay with him and i'm aiming for
those kazushi powders you see it right
here
now the question is how do you generate
the kazushi pattern okay so he's going
again
it's going to be the same one you see do
i generate it
by an external pull and an external push
could you
yes it's the same geometry but
it's not the internal aspects of the art
okay
the way i'm going to do it is with
an ik adhesion on this arm
we won't define it yet but i'm going to
demonstrate it
do you see it's and then
with a cocky projection on this arm
[Music]
noted by my arm not going in and out
okay
so what are they
well his energy with his intention
trying to hitch me
is of being allowed to pass into me
it's going to pass into me you see
heaven comes through man hits the earth
and i'm going to release it
if i release it in a positive young
he will be displaced so we'll go we'll
do that one again
a little quicker you see
the yin the ikey is going to be
his energies going into me into me
but i only release it so that it's
neutral if i push on it it would be a
cocky projection
right if i go negative i'm going to come
off of him
okay so the energy is coming
with this hand on the technique we
showed had the ik adhesion
i keep the energetic output
equal to his that's what creates this
friction
or i like to say the universe does what
the universe does i let it do
okay that means i have an equivalent
energetic output universe doesn't know
that those are two separate things and
treats it as one thing
that's what happens okay so
don't contest but you'll see push
he's he's in these traps already use
meaning the energetic traps okay use
them
to find the kazushi here's gonna be your
call cube
here's gonna be your ip
so he's trying to do his thing i stay
with him there it is
it gets kind of silly but it's
ritualistic
because you're you're going to find the
kazushi pattern
easy easy it's easy
so work on other things
do the adhesion a little extra
okay so
i'm not contested in two ways
an external way i yield and i stay with
him
and the internal way the immaterial
passes through the material got it
that is the ultimate non-contention it
passes through me
both through and both out
so you can have like these skeletal
alignments you see
and do these skeletal alignments
that's not that's external okay
so i don't want to find you're trying to
get the chest
i don't want to find you see there it is
right there did you see it and you going
so go out all we're going to do skeletal
alignment
you see that's not it okay
i am
just doing energetic projections
so what what is that what does that mean
how does it look like okay
so usually what you're going to see is
i uh don't bend your joints
you see and then i bend your joints and
then
i push your joint
so here i'm going to push around this
axis point like this
do you see that i don't want to do that
it go
right where i'm touching you is in do
you see the difference
so which direction would you describe
that
my touch point extend it with your hand
really i'll show you what that feels
like
let's try it again
which way which way
yes you see not not like this
not like
so where we touch you see and so i can
turn it
not mechanical
so this would be stopping you straight
come back up energetic it's going around
okay so i won't learn this if
i am pushing
like this or like this
you see that where you're touching
oh center
but it's not that i'm going center
you could go up
you see that it cleared it out
but still in your center okay